Land und Brecht
[Musik]
immer noch Sommer in Hamburg Richard
freue mich zweiter Teil ja es war so
spannend hier zuzuhören über Darwin und
Arten und Diversität und vor allen
Dingen über sexuelle Selektion genau da
sie bestehen geblieben genau
[Gelächter]
hinguckt fällt das ja erst nicht so auf
ne das ähm die die Art und Weise wie der
Konkurrenzkampf unter Menschen
stattfindet ja der genetische Kampf um
Durchsetzung und Interessen und so ja
nicht
elementaren natürlich im Wettkampf
entspricht sondern es entscheidend sich
Nachkommen kriegt man und die Frage wie
viel Nachkommen ist eine Frage was für
ein Partner bekommt man
und der Kampf der Partnerwahl ja das ist
sozusagen der Selektionsmechanismus der
erste der zweite ist natürlich die
eigene Entscheidung wie viel Kinder man
kriegen klar aber die also evolutionär
was ist denn unsere Aufgabe was ist
unsere Bestimmung ich habe immer also
anders dieses Bild sozusagen dass da
entstanden ist ja
die Tierwelt die Arten dann wird ja
biologistisch argumentiert dann wird ja
mit Instinkten argumentiert und ich frag
mich dann immer kann man das sozusagen
eins zu eins einfach auf Menschen
übertragen ja also sind wir wirklich nur
ein Haufen Instinkte und ist sozusagen
unser biologischer Job unser
gegenmaterial ja so großflächig ich
finde wirklich gut das Volk zu bringen
heißt dann im Falle eines attraktiven
Mannes wie dir einfach dafür zu sorgen
dass es möglichst viele von deiner Art
gibt oder ist das möglicherweise gar
nicht der Sinn der Zweck vielleicht ist
alles ganz anders na ja ein attraktiver
Mann wie du hat so weit dass der
Öffentlichkeit bekannt ist ja keine
tausende von Nachkommen mhm oder
wahrscheinlich die Möglichkeit dazu
gehabt hätte das heißt also die die kann
mich nicht erinnern dein genetischer
Auftrag würde ja darin bestehen nicht zu
rasten noch zu ruhen bis jedes Kind in
Hamburg nach deinem Bilder angefertigt
ist und wahrscheinlich hast du in deinem
Leben Gründe gehabt ich verlasse
ja die sehen alle aus wie ich also das
war schon mit 14 angefangen
genetischen Antrieb wer ist Menschen
drin aber er bestimmt die nicht als
einziges ne das ist dann vielleicht das
was uns von relativ primitiven Lebewesen
unterscheidet ich glaube schon bei
anderen hochkomplexen Säugetieren wie
bei Primaten oder sowas ja Menschenaffen
gibt es schon noch ein bisschen mehr als
nur dem dem Wunsch der Gene zu gehorchen
also das auch interessant weil
Schimpansen z.B dass ich Schimpansen
Weibchen nicht notwendig in den obersten
Boss ja den nicht in den reichsten
mächtigsten und stärksten das Alphatier
ne für kurze Zeit ja sondern es muss
nicht das Alphatier sein das kann auch
dieser Junge Hansel sein ja den man
irgendwie ganz witzig findet dass das
meine ich also auch da so unsere
Vorstellung wird es letztes Mal erzählt
wie wie sehr das dann auch missbraucht
worden ist die Idee sozusagen dieses
Darwinismus survival of the fittest
genau das Alphatier also genau der
stärkste setzt sich durch genau aber in
der Tierwelt ich ich also wenn man mit
mit sich entsprechender Literatur
beschäftigt merkt man ganz schnell
Alphatier bedeutet für Biologen nichts
zwingend der Stärkste der skrupelloses
der rücksichtsloseste sondern heißt was
ganz anderes wer ist das einfach hier
auf dem affenhügel also am Ende würde
man sagen der der die meisten Nachkommen
produziert das ist natürlich jetzt auf
dem Pavian Felsen in der Regelfall schon
der oberste Wurst ne da ist das so aber
also der
obere Möglichkeit eine Möglichkeit
überhaupt abzurechnen ist ne gewonnen
hat er mit den meisten Nachkommen ob der
stark war wie der da ist das nein nein
aber das meine ich ja und jetzt gibt's
natürlich schon so Gesellschaften wo die
die anderen nicht so zum Zuge kommen
wieder oberste Boss das wäre jetzt
dieses Beispiel wo das ist aber ich
dachte ja schon bei Menschenaffen da
kann es passieren gibt's auch den
obersten Boss also im Fall von Gorillas
gibt's was mein Schimpansen und wenn
Schimpansen ist es so dass die rein
niedrigeren Männchen durchaus zu ihrem
kommen ja die müssen natürlich ein
bisschen tricksen und die rein
niedrigeren Weibchen ebenfalls zu ihrem
Kommen und da spielen schon andere
Qualitäten eigentlich nur eben der
größte mächtigste und stärkste zu sein
Bonobos sind ja auch interessant die
lösen ja ihre Konflikte mit
Geschlechtsverkehr genau da gibt's gar
kein obersten Boss über den Bonus nee
das ist also wenn überhaupt Material hat
also eigentlich in die Weibchen die
schwierige Regeln sind interessant ja
und das ist dann Natur klappt super mit
dem so schlecht also die die Männchen
erkennt man im Zoo schon mal gerne daran
dass ihnen der Finger abgebissen ist
oder was ähnlich ist da werden die
Weibchen häufig ziemlich fies okay ja
schon klar was böses aber die lösen ihre
Konflikte mit Geschlechtsverkehr immer
wenn irgendeine Spannung ist und ein
Druck dann gibt es Geschlechtsverkehr
und dann ist wieder gut also so Hippie
Affen die Kommune 1 wurde halt nicht von
Rainer langhan erfunden sondern die
Bonobos praktizieren noch die
Missionarsstellung übrigens ja die
eigentlich bonobosstellung heißen müsste
ist der einzige Affe der die regelmäßig
benutzt ist so ja in allen anderen ist
der klassische sex von hinten ja und bei
bei Bonobos gibt's das auch aber es gibt
eben auch Missionars das heißt sie sind
sehr kreativ auch schon mal gerne an
beim Sex und so ja sind interessant ja
verbringen auch sehr viel Zeit in ihrem
Leben damit es sind interessantes
Konzept warum nicht der Mensch ist ja
irgendwas dazwischen ne also ein
bisschen uns ja aber auch ein bisschen
von dem
hierarchisch Denken von der Idee genau
ja das müssen ja nicht in der
menschlichen Kulturgeschichte immer die
Männer sein vielleicht werden das ja
auch demnächst die Frauen aber dieses
Hierarchie denken das ist ja das wird
nicht gänzlich aus der Menschenwelt
verschwinden und dieses Hierarchie
denken das ist eben bei Bonobos sehr
gering entwickelt und wir sind irgendwas
verunglücktes also halb Bruno groß oder
halb normale schwimmen ist denn
überhaupt die Theorie haltbar sozusagen
dass dann die attraktivsten Mensch also
in der Biologie es gibt ja Merkmale wo
man sagen okay jemand wie du du bist
jetzt sozusagen aus der Sicht eines
Biologen bist du das attraktiver
das Kind ja also noch mehr Kinder ja und
noch stärkere Augenbrauen und noch
Muskeln und noch mehr Körpergröße und so
weiter also davon könnte es ja
eigentlich gar nicht genug geben wenn
ihr zwei Meter groß bist und riesen
Kreuz hast und so weiter tiefe Stimme
das sind eigentlich die die klassischen
rein biologisch
ist ja so aus dass man sich guckt wie
sehen die Sex Symbole an Männern in
Hollywood aus man relativ wenig davon
findet wer findet da eine relativ große
Zahl bei Brad Pitt ist nicht besonders
groß Johnny Depp ist ja feminin die dem
also nicht eins zu eins oder so richtig
sprechen das kann man sagen Mensch es
sind zwischen die generiert und so ein
bisschen sozusagen von seinem aralischen
Bild abgewichen man kann auch sagen
vielleicht haben die Biologen da auch
was massiv übertrieben also vielleicht
kommt es ja nicht unbegrenzt der Masse
oder die Superlative
19 interessantes Interview gelesen mit
Franz der Wahl der ein tolles Buch
gemacht hat über die Frage was wir von
Primaten über Gendern lernen können oh
jetzt bin ich gespannt also der der Kern
der Geschichte ist ganz einfach er sagt
die Natur will eigentlich Vielfalt und
ist viel viel toleranter Primaten sind
unendlich viel toleranter als ihr also
wir sagt er kennt sich auch
sagen nebenjango Dell der bedeutendste
lebende prima so genau und der und er
sagt das ist das was ich dort beobachten
lässt also in der Welt der Daten geht es
sehr sehr tolerant zu also über die
Bonobos habe eben gerade schon
gesprochen da könnte auch eine gewisse
grundtoleranz dazu er sagt doch da gibt
es Homosexualität da gibt es mal so mal
so denn wenn wir über Trans Menschen
reden wir über Trans Primaten reden
würden das ist in der Tierwelt alles
überhaupt kein Problem es sind wir die
sozusagen dann das Spektrum verengen
völlig interessant
also wenn man dem Pfad so folgt
die haben natürlich keine begrifflichen
Konzepte also die sortieren sich nicht
in begriffswelten ein das ist der
Unterschied und das heißt die sind auch
nicht gekränkt wenn die falschen Worte
benutzt werden über sie ja oder wenn sie
sich falsch klassifiziert sehen das sind
ja alles wird also der der Mensch ist
sicherlich also zumindestens der der in
Berlin Mitte lebt die Spezies die am
versessensten darauf ist ständig
beleidigt und gekränkt zu sein und das
wird sich in gleichem Maße
wahrscheinlich im Urwald der
Zentralafrikanische Republik nicht
wiederfinden ich würde mal sagen wir
haben ja über Evolution gesprochen ich
glaube nicht dass das ein Vorteil hat
sondern ich bin ja bei der Theorie jeder
Scheiß kann überleben solange nicht zum
Aussterben führt und dann kann man sich
auch in bestimmten Kulturen auf diese
Art und Weise Hyper sind wievielisieren
solange es nicht zum Aussterben führt
kann das in der Welt existieren
der Wahl des da sehr interessant sagt
eigentlich gibt es sozusagen diese diese
Verhärtung die wir da sehen ne die hat
was damit zu tun dass Biologen eben
lange Zeit immer nur über Instinkt
argumentiert haben so das ist eben der
Instinkt der Natur und dann gibt es dann
Instinktes Alpha Rüden und die sind dann
so ja und Frauen sind irgendwie ganz
anders und so weiter und das überträgt
man dann auf Menschenbild und dann
entsteht er plötzlich ne werden
Geschlechter so in Front gegeneinander
gebracht aber er sagt eigentlich gibt's
dafür überhaupt keinen Grund sondern
eigentlich wenn man sich das Tierreich
anschaut funktioniert das gerade bei den
Privaten anders das finde ich sehr
interessant er sagt aber auch
gleichzeitig natürlich gibt es keinen
entkommen was die Biologie angeht also
wir sind schon auch sozusagen sehr
geprägt von dem was unsere Natur
umsetzen mal sozusagen ist und er
beschreibt dann interessantes Experiment
und sagt wenn privaten Babys Kinder
wenn die Spielzeuge vorgelegt kriegen
dann dann greifen Primaten Jungs
automatisch zum Laster und die Mädchen
greifen zur Puppe und keiner weiß so
genau warum
Gespräch was wohl ein Primaten an
schimpansenkindmessung Laster anfängt ja
was der dem sagt aber es ist interessant
der Junge greift zu diesem Laster das
heißt eigentlich ist sozusagen die die
der der der Stand der Dinge du kannst
über deine Biologie nicht wirklich
einfach hinweg gehen aber natürlich
kannst du sie sozusagen beeinflussen
natürlich spielt kulturelle Interaktion
eine gigantische Rolle weil der der du
bist bist du natürlich immer in einem
ganz bestimmten Kontakte in Berlin Mitte
und mal in der Zentralafrikanischen
Republik genau und jetzt ist das
interessante also wenn man guckt wie ist
der der Austausch zwischen dem
biologischen und dem kulturellen wenn
man sich die Frage stellt welcher Pavian
wird oberster Boss auf dem Pavian Hügel
jetzt hier die Mantelpaviane die doch so
immer und in der Natur auf diesen Felsen
sind genau so wer wird der August ganz
einfach der stärkste so simpel ist das
der stärkste Kraft oder der Smart ist
der stärkste der stärkste wirklich
weiß ist schon ziemlich hafte Gesellen
also der stärkste jetzt muss der
stärkste nicht über den höchsten
Testosteronspiegel verfügen das sind
zwar völlig verschiedene Dinge auch bei
Menschen richtig ja also es muss nicht
sein dass Arnold Schwarzenegger ein
zehnmal höheren Testosteronspiegel hat
als irgend so ein kleiner zarter Mensch
im Büro
also du kannst du kannst den
Testosteronspiegel am Äußeren nicht so
sauber ablesen wie man denkt
so es ist aber so wenn der Pavian mal
ganz ganz oben auf dem Felsen angekommen
ist
verziehen facht sich sein
testosteronspiegeln durch soziale
Anerkennung durch Status durch Status
und Anerkennung ja und das gleiche hast
du bei Menschen auch also wenn du
Geschäftsführer von irgendwas bist oder
Kanzler oder was was ich was dann erhöht
sich als Mann dein testoster
nachweisbar ganz ganz erheblich schon
mal gemessen bei mir ja nee ich weiß
auch nicht wie man Testosteronspiegel
ist hast ne aber das können wir ja mal
gemeinsam machen noch mal gucken
ja aber also
deswegen ist auch der Verlust eines
solchen Amtes für Männer jetzt aus alles
jetzt aus der Männer Perspektive
gesprochen auch entsprechend tragisch
weil mit dem Verlust des Amtes ja
beginnt also sozusagen der Abstieg vom
Felsen und dann geht auch deine
Körperchemie verändert sich in
Wirklichkeit mache
ich bin abgesehen davon dass wir
Wahrheit aber dazu sagen dass das Sohn
verblödet
ja also je mehr du davon hast ja ja umso
umso kürzer werden im Regelfall auch
tatsächlich deine Gedanken und du wirst
zwar möglicherweise ein guter Redner
aber ein sehr schlechter Zuhörer ja und
das Beginnen sozusagen diese diese
Testosteron Vergiftung ja das ist ein
gewisser sozialer verdummungseffekt weil
die Rolle des führenden
primatenmännchens ist die simpels die es
gibt du musst nur darauf achten dass ihr
kein anderer Mann gefährlich werden kann
oder die Frauen klaut ist eine sehr
simple Auftrag die inklamaten sind die
Mittelalter im alten Weibchen
die sich um die Jungen kümmern müssen
die vielleicht den obersten Boss gar
nicht gut finden und die Gelegenheit
finden irgendjemand anderen schöner
Augen zu machen das darf aber nicht groß
Ausfall auffallen dafür muss braucht man
Freundinnen die in der Zeit auf die
Kinder aufpassen oder den großen Boss
ablenken und so weiter das heißt das
soziale Schach was die Weibchen spielen
ist viel komplizierter als das was die
Menschen spielen und deswegen sind bei
Primaten versuchen und auch was die
berühmten Primaten anbelangt also wir
fallen nur zwei außen haben aber nein
der versucht Schimpanse nehmen und der
Bonobo kann sie aber die meisten
berühmten Menschenaffen mit dem man
Experimente gemacht Sprache beigebracht
und sowas im Regelfall man die Weibchen
dafür interessant du hattest doch
neulich Jürgen Schmidhuber ne das ist
schon ein bisschen ja ja aber war auch
bei uns in der Sendung ist ein
wahnsinnig faszinierender mann muss an
den gerade denken ki-pionieren ja der ja
alles über neuronale Netzwerke weiß und
so weiter
und der sagte wir sind ja im Grunde
sozusagen so eine Verkettung von
Neuronen und üben dann so langsam ja ein
kleines Kind fängt dann an irgendwann
Fußball zu spielen und so weiter und das
ist das was KI heute noch überhaupt
nicht kann also selbst Lernende Systeme
nicht hinter einem Bildschirm sondern in
der realen Welt also laufen joggen
Fußball spielen Tennis spielen schwimmen
all diese Dinge die Kinder lernen indem
sie merken okay das ist schlecht das ist
auch schlecht das ist gut das wird zum
Erfolg das funktioniert das kann KI
heute noch nicht aber er sagt wir sind
dabei das zu imitieren und sagte dann
auf die Frage ob das bei Jungs besser
geht als bei Mädchen frauen sind da im
Vorteil evolutionär weil die mehr von
diesen Verknüpfungen verschalteungen im
Kopf haben als Männer und das
wahrscheinlich auf aus Neuro
anatomischen Grund sondern ja das ist
ein bisschen umstritten also ist
berühmte Korpus Carlos und die die
Brücke zwischen dem rechten linken
Gehirn da gibt es also sehr
unterschiedliche Ergebnisse sondern weil
es großen Unterschied macht ob du von
östradiolen überschwemmt wirst oder von
Testosteron okay also die
Eindimensionalität des menschlichen
Denkens hat wahrscheinlich mehr mit der
Software zu tun als mit der Hardware und
die okay und die Software ist in dem
Fall Testosteron ja die die Nachteil ist
die nachteilige
auch damit zusammen dass du natürlich
dann auch leichter aggressiv wirst oder
solche Dinge ne und wir sind mindestens
einig also Menschen sind in dem Moment
wo sie aggressiv sind selten besonders
intelligent richtig bei der Zustand ist
nicht darauf ausgerichtet sehr
zielstrebig drauf ausgerichtet eine
einzige Botschaft zu sehen richtig
entweder mit körperlicher Gewalt oder
mit mit Wortgewalt wer Angst hat kann
ich mir denken ja genau das ist klar
genau und wenn der wütend ist auch nicht
das richtig hat das eigentlich ne
Evolution auch eine gute Funktion ist es
wirklich nur der Sinn der Übung du
solltest dich denken sondern du sollst
sozusagen
ja also der Mensch hat ja die ganze
Palette in sich es gibt haben Momente da
bist du einfach nur Tier ja da kommt ja
gut Ausbruch Chris oder sowas alles
Karneval auch zum Beispiel die lustvolle
Verwandlung von dir zu Bier mehr ans
Tier heran also das Interessante ist wir
lernen jetzt immer mehr davon wie viel
Tiere wir sind gerade auch wo du ja von
schwedower sprichst im Zeitalter der
künstlichen Intelligenz können wir uns
nicht mehr unterscheiden als die
rationalen Wesen ja die Philosophen ja
immer gemacht
Rationalität Logos und so weiter und
andere Pflanzen Instinkt sondern jetzt
müssen wir sagen ach nee ist ein
bisschen anders ja KI ist ganz rational
und wir so Menschen Tiere Pflanzen
wurden auf einmal wieder ziemlich nah
zusammen entdecken sozusagen immer mehr
unsere animalische Verstrickung wir
lernen immer mehr wie faszinierend wie
komplexe Tiere sind ich habe ja schon
viel übertragen geredet irrsinnig
fasziniert und in der gleichen Zeit wo
wir das alles erforschen und Wissen
Worten wir die in einem gnadenlosen
Affen anal aus
also das ist ja der große Widerspruch
unserer Zeit und wenn das so weitergeht
dann landen wir da was der große
Evolutionsbiologe adword Wilson der
letzten Jahre gesprochen haben genau
getroffen die habe ich leider leider nie
getroffen hätte ich gerne mal getroffen
ich habe noch getroffen ja
faszinierende Frau
genau ja aber Ihnen also da war ja quasi
der bedeutendste evolutionsbüro auch
eine Legende seiner selbst und der hat
gesagt wir gehen jetzt in ein neues
Zeitalter ein ist übrigens ein bisschen
Hobby neue Erdzeitalter erfinden
ich bin gegen den Begriff bist du ja
wenig weil
Menschen dient dem Menschen nicht
sagen der Mensch hinterlässt mir solche
Spuren solche Spuren in der Natur ja was
also früher die Zeiten die Stürme die
Vulkanausbrüche die Meeresspiegel
Veränderungen und so gemacht haben das
macht jetzt alles der Mensch richtig
dass wir das anthropozin nennen weil der
Mensch pflügt ja im Augenblick die Erde
um und ich glaube nicht dass ist der
Mensch ist weil es gibt ganz viele
Menschen die Fliegen die Erde überhaupt
nicht um deine Inuits tun das nicht ja
und die Leute im Ituri Urwald Leben
machen das nicht und die Leute am Amazon
machen nur die Kulturen in denen das
Geld im Mittelpunkt steht nur die
und deswegen habe ich ja vorgeschlagen
man sollte dass das moneto 10 nennen das
Zeitalter des Geldes weil das Geld fügt
letztlich ist der Mensch stellt sich
sozusagen in den Dienst des Geld total
interessant sagt übrigens auch also neue
Technologien echt der disruption
wirklich spektakuläre Entwicklung
entsteht und entstand immer dort wo das
Geld war das große Geld die große
Entwicklung kommt immer aus dem Geld ja
also dann also du und ich eigentlich
Monitor sehen meine Petition machen
unbedingt aber es gibt auch im anderen
schönen Begriff von Edward Wilson und
der spricht vom eremito
vom Zeitalter der Einsamkeit wir werden
so viele Arten ausrotten dass wir einsam
werden zum Beispiel muss man sich mal
vorstellen bei Säugetieren gibt es viel
viel mehr Nutztiere in der Welt als
Wildtiere es gibt mehr Rinderhaltung und
mehr schweinehaltigen scharfe Haltung
Ziegenhaltung als es Wildtiere auf der
ganzen Welt gibt es wirklich ein
Antilopen und so weiter in absoluten
können
nutzt Säugetierarten die wir überhaupt
halten
verglichen mit hunderten von Arten oder
einigen tausend Arten von Säugetieren
immer das natürlich völlig richtig
erinnere mich an einen Gespräch mit
einem Pharma an der Grenze Arizona
Mexiko wie vor Jahren mal getroffen sehr
interessanter Mann der der mit seiner
Frau alleine da in diesem Drogendealer
Sinaloa Kartell der der lebt da auf
einer riesigen Farm der 10.000 Rinder
nur der würde überlegt wie viele Löwen
gibt es noch in freier Wildbahn und
nicht viel mehr einige tausend also
genau
mein Arizona dessen Sohn übrigens sehr
interessant das Leben ist manchmal so
verrückt ich frag ihn ob er Kinder hat
er wohnt da ganz alleine und die machen
da diese Farben und der ist schon alter
Mann und er sagte ja niemand Sohn der
ist in Kalifornien der Spielentwickler
der unter anderem World of Warcraft mit
entwickelt
der Vater der die 10.000 drin da hält
die wir übrigens auf der Fahrt über
seinen riesiges Gelände ich habe keine
einzige
davon gesehen nicht eine so groß war das
Gelände so riesig unvorstellbar
unvorstellbar aber das nur am Rande aber
das heißt wir wir halten also auf die
Tiere zurück zu kommen wir halten viel
mehr Nutztiere als das Wildtiere gibt
und wenn du gerade von Löwen gesprochen
hast es gibt ja nur einen Grund warum es
noch Löwen gibt ich meine es gibt fast
alle Löwen die es gibt Leben in
Nationalparks gibt es weil sie auch ein
funktionierendes Geschäft Safari wieder
Geld ja genau also wieder Zeit als er
das Geld ist aber das heißt die Theorie
von Wissens wir werden einsam wir werden
einsam weil wir eben Millionen von
Tierarten weiter ausrotten werden und
diese diese diese Gedanke dass wir quasi
in einer beliebten Welt leben wird
eigentlich immer weniger spürbar wir
sehen das ja jetzt schon durch
insektensterben freuen sich viele
darüber keine Wespenstiche und so wobei
Westen gibt's immer im Spätsommer und
die profitieren die sind nicht so
zentral betroffen ne vom vom Insekten
sterben aber Insekten sterben führt zu
singen Vogel sterben und die weniger
Tiere noch da leise es wird leise andere
Sachen werden laut ja die Menschen
werden laut und so weiter aber
die Natur führt weniger sichtbar und
schon vor ich glaube jetzt inzwischen 25
30 Jahren hat die Kölner Uni meine
Umfrage gemacht wie viel heimische
Pflanzen können Sie bestimmen und dann
haben sie gefragt wie viel Automarken
sie unterscheiden der Automarken haben
haushoch gewonnen gut damals waren die
Autos auch noch unterschiedliche aus als
heute
sehen wir alle gleich aus
von wenigen Ausnahmen abgesehen aber
das wäre schon mal spannend die haben
auch Umfragen und Biologiestudenten
gemacht ja wie viele Baumarten sie
unterscheiden können und so weiter
dieses Wissen schluckt aus es ist fast
nichts mehr da wenn dieses Wissen nicht
mehr da ist und man ist nicht kennt
betrauert man auch den Verlust nicht es
fällt einem also auch nicht mehr so
vermisst war nur entwickelt sich auch
keine Liebe zu Dingen die du nicht
kennst wie spannend sowas ist klar wenn
du dich damit beschäftigt aber in der
Alltagswelt unserer Kinder wenn das
alles sowieso nicht mehr vorkommt ich
meine früher sind Kinder aus Spaß
irgendwie in den Wald gegangen oder so
gibt's heute nicht mehr heute hat man
Angst dem passiert irgendwas fieses im
Wald das andere ist was soll ein Kind im
Wald schon großartiges erleben das ist
doch sozusagen vom Adrenalin Auslosung
ist nichts vergleichbar mit dem was sie
ausgefuchste spielelektronik einstellt
aber wie soll man in dem Moment wo es
darum geht wir müssen alle Kräfte dafür
sensibilisieren die Natur zu schützen
und nicht eben nur das Klima ja sondern
eben auch das Aussterben der Arten und
so weiter das alles verschwindet wenn
man sich ein geschwind hat so nichts
mehr auslöst man keine Gefühle mehr
dahin
Kagel norwegischer Abenteurer der war
mal bei uns in der Sendung und und saß
dann barfuß einfach in in diesem
Fernsehstudio rum das finde ich sehr
lustig ist ein interessanter Mann großer
Kunstsammler und so weiter weil halt
auch ein großer Abenteurer der dieses
schöne kannst du dünnes Buch über die
Stille geschrieben hat und wo wo er sagt
wie wertvoll eigentlich Stille sein kann
aber was umgekehrt sozusagen auch Lärm
macht und und erzählt darin das z.B
Vögel anfangen in Städten um sich
überhaupt noch zu hören ihre Frequenzen
zu verändern hohe Frequenzen Vögel die
früher deutlich tiefer gesungen haben
sind jetzt höher um gegen diesen
grundlärm dieses Grundrauschen irgendwie
noch anzukommen Tiere was was für eine
irre Leistung ja die mit der Darwinschen
Theorie auch nicht mal eben so erklärt
ist ja denn das bräuchte ich eine
irrsinnig lange Zeit bis da irgendwelche
Vorteile und wie auch immer und so also
wir haben die das Rätsel der Evolution
auch noch nicht hinein Aspekten
entblättert das sagt Dirk Steffens auch
ja das war immer so dass jede Generation
von Forschern dachte jetzt haben wir was
na und sicherlich ist vieles von dem was
Darwin erkannte zeitlos richtig aber es
ist keine vollständige Erklärung von
alles und allem und ich glaube ich hätte
meine lustige Anekdote die nicht gut für
mich ausführen ich war mal im
Naturkundemuseum in Berlin vor 10 Jahren
12 Jahren zu einer Tagung das andere
waren alles bio-professoren und ich
hatte dann Vortrag gehalten über über
David und
über Prinzip hier in der Evolution und
solche Sachen und nachher saßen wir beim
Abendessen zusammen acht Leuten am Tisch
und dann habe ich gesagt nachher wir
sitzen eigentlich ganz viel ist nicht
also warum ein Birkenspanner ja so ein
alter eins zu eins aussieht wie
Birkenrinde
das kann ich mit so einfach mal eben so
mit David nicht erklären weil man sagen
muss ja nie wieso der hat sich angepasst
und die angepassten die hatten dann
Vorteile das stimmt aber nicht den
Vorteil hast du erst am Ende der
Entwicklung wenn du eins zu eins die
Birkenrinde aus wenn du aber ein weißer
Falter bist ja ein winzig kleinen
braunen lecker hast du überhaupt keinen
Vorteil der ganzen Weg da drauf bringt
gar nichts ist richtig ja das heißt also
du kannst über diese anpassungstheorie
den Vorteil nicht erklären das ist
genauso wie der Vogelflug ja da hast du
genau dasselbe Problem mit dem Vorteil
fliegen zu können verstehe ich aber den
Vorteil Federn zu haben ohne fliegen zu
können und oder so zum klein bisschen
flattern können und sowas dass das eine
Vorteil ist Selektion weiß
unwahrscheinlich es gibt eine Reihe von
Erklärung dafür sag mal du bist
beschäftigt sich sicher waren sie ja
also es gibt alberne Erklärung ja
richard dockings ist so mein
Lieblingsfeind der für triviale
Erklärung von Evolution gefressen den
habe ich völlig gefühlt also alles was
Übertreibung
egoistische Gene ja das ist also das ist
immer alles holzhackerisch simpel das
ist der Autor von Gottes Wahnsinn
weg damit Gottes nicht weil wir haben ja
über Religion häufig geredet ja ähm
jemand anders die Religion austreiben zu
wollen finde ich es kein edles Motiv gut
also da bin ich der Meinung jeder soll
nach seiner Fassung glücklich werden und
die alle für verrückt zu erklären und
für Verbrecher und so weiter dass mir
einfach viel zu simpel
ist wieder das gleiche ich verstehe
seine Kritik aber in dieser Form in der
die vorgetragen wird finde akzeptabel
und in dem Buch der Gotteswahn ja
erklärt er wie die Vögel zum Fliegen kam
kann jeder danach lesen da geht es also
darum das ist Dinosaurier gegeben haben
sollte auf Bäumen
naja vielleicht vielleicht auch nicht so
und die mit den Fehlern die Waren im
Vorteil weil wenn die runterfielen dann
seht ihr ja nicht quasi zermatscht auf
dem Boden sondern konnten sich irgendwo
abfangen
doch ich meine so eine Theorie kann man
sich in der stillen Stunde auf dem Klo
irgendwo ausdenken ja es kann eine von
1000 denkbaren Theorien die man sich
ausdenken kann dann muss er immer noch
die Frage stellen warum hatten die
vorher den schon Federn wo kam denn die
Federn her und wo soll der Vorteil
dieser Federn gewesen sein als sie noch
winzig klein waren und zum abfedern
nicht geeignet waren also ich glaube
Josef reichwolf dieser Münchner
Evolutionsbiologe der Admir Theorie
vorgelegt die mir bisher am besten
gefallen und das ist wenn Vögel sehr
schnell laufen dann produzieren sie viel
von dem Stoff aus dem dieses Horn ist
und das könnt ihr dazu geführt haben
dass wir diese kleinen schnell
wachsenden Dinosaurier dass die
irgendwann gefiedert war nicht weil das
Vorteile brachte auch nicht weil ihm
kalt war oder so sondern war das von
Überproduktion kam das zu viel Horn
produziert wurde durch das Laufen okay
und dass dieses Horn quasi in Form von
Federn aus diesem Vögel quasi
rausgewachsen ist da werden wir wieder
bei der Theorie ein nicht tödlicher
Nachteil also Quatsch eigentlich oder
nicht ja aber war halt ging halt deshalb
passiert genau und ab einem bestimmten
Punkt
und ich denke wenn wir solche
Überlegungen überhaupt mit aufnehmen
dann kommen wir der Sache sicher näher
als wenn wir immer denken das muss man
anfangen Vorteil gehabt haben
diese einsamkeitstheorien ich ich muss
jetzt gerade an Humboldt denken ja ich
meine ist ja der andere große in dem
Zusammenhang über die Mama reden muss
ein bisschen früher ne schon ja und
unterwegs genau so gute 200 Jahre zur 69
+ 18,9
gibt doch dieses großartige Buch von
Andrea Wolf ja noch so sehr zu empfehlen
Deutsche die in London lebt ja die mich
immer ihre beeindruckt mit dem was sie
über Humboldt weiß und die auch diese
Dimension verstanden hat dass das fand
ich ja wiederum etwas was mir so ein
bisschen Glauben an die Menschheit
zurückgegeben hat dass wenn ich alle
komplette Verblödung an Heim fallen ich
meine es ist 21 Jahrhundert ja und dann
kommt jemand wie Andrea Wulff und
schreibt ein Buch über einen Mann der
200 Jahren gelebt hat wichtige Dinge
getan hat aber alles wird so Retro und
zack Bestseller weil so viele Leute
plötzlich fasziniert sind von dem was da
drin steht und verstehen welche Größe
welche Dimension das hat auch zum Thema
Umweltschutz der erste der darüber
nachgedacht hat das ist ein co2-effekt
gibt der erste der in ich glaube in
Venezuela war es ein sehr beobachtet hat
wo klar war da kippt jetzt gerade ein
ganzes Ökosystem ja beschreibt diese
Situation da steigen diese diese
wunderschönen Fischreiher und die
Kranich und alles steigt da so auf im
Gegenlicht und alles ist wunderschön
und plötzlich wird ihm klar das ist aber
eine Welt die gerade untergeht warum
weil rund um diesen See einfach alles
abgeholzt worden war und er hat
verstanden diese Bäume diese Wurzeln das
war nur das biotisch genau genau
kommt und so weiter und er konnte quasi
in Echtzeit zusehen wie der
Wasserspiegel nach unten geht und das
andere war eben dieses Thema und da wird
ja mehr also kriegt man Gänsehaut aber
beschreibt wir werden wahrscheinlich
irgendwann so fern den Planeten Reisen
und dann wenn wir die ähnlich kaputt
machen wie den auf den wir gerade sind
und das alles gestohlen 150 Jahren
wahnsinnig faszinierend ja Darwin und er
ja kannten sich oder kannten sich nicht
es gibt eine Anekdote dass Sie sich wohl
in London Mal begegnet sind und das ich
weiß nicht wie belastbar die Anekdote
ist und das Darwin wohl leicht genervt
von Humboldt war bei der zu viel geredet
hat
ich weiß gar nicht ehrlich gesagt wie
gut Alexander von Humboldt Englisch
konnte das weiß ich nicht französisch
konnte er wunderbar weiter ganz lange in
Paris gelebt bei Englisch weiß ich nicht
so genau weiß also nicht ob das jetzt
noch für David übersetzt werden musste
die Vermessung der Welt ja großartiges
Buch und da gibt's sehr schnell am
Anfang kommt diese schöne Anekdote aus
hat keinen Bock zum großen Kongress zu
fahren lässt sich aber von Humboldt
bequatschen und und windet sich und uns
hielt sich und will partout nicht in
diese Kutsche einsteigen und irgendwann
sitzt da endlich eher der größte
Mathematiker des Landes in dieser
elenden Kutsche auf dem Weg fest bricht
er in Berlin auf und irgendwann fragt er
seinen Sohn Eugen der neben ihm sitzt
immer warum heiratet deine Schwester
eigentlich nicht
und Eugen den kurz nach und sagt Vater
wahrscheinlich weil sie hässlich ist und
aus schwieg Punkt die Antwort der schien
ihm plausibel
das ist so großartig also die haben sich
offenkundig getroffen
aber Darwin und Humboldt offenbar
vielleicht also ich weiß nicht ob man es
weiß ich weiß es jedenfalls nicht also
ich weiß dass es diese Anekdote gibt ich
weiß nicht wie belastbar die ist super
aber die Bedeutung von Humboldt in dem
Zusammenhang als was ich irre finde bei
Humboldt wo gar nicht so viel darüber
geredet wird also wenn jemand groß wird
im damaligen Berlin
das ist so Feudalzeit pur das ist so die
Zeit wo die ersten Prachtbauten Unter
den Linden davon Knobelsdorf und so
gemacht werden sind also in so einer
Barock und Rocko Welt und wenn er dann
stirbt ja
1859 tobt die industrielle Revolution
das heißt dass du vorhin erzählt hast
mit dem See und dann Zerstörung und so
also da fahren dann Eisenbahnen ja und
da werden steilwerke gebaut und und
Textilfabriken gibt es auch schon lange
also er kriegt diesen gesamten Wandel
mit disruption ja von der
Adelsgesellschaft zu bürgerlichen
Gesellschaft politisch aber auch eben
diese Natur Vernichtung die einhergeht
mit der industriellen Revolution
also quasi aus der der Idylle einer
ungerechten adelswelt in die Barbarei
einer im Vergleich gerechteren
bürgerlichen Welt rein und er ist
Zeitzeuge dieser gesamten also quasi
jahrhundertfigur Wahnsinn und als junger
Mensch eben so lange in seiner Reise
unterwegs gewesen und Entdeckungen
gemacht ich meine hat ja für alles
interessiert und was ich immer sehr
beeindruckend finde ich meine ich war in
meinem Leben ja auch schon das ein oder
andere Mal im Regenwald manchmal auch
schon mal lange und was war deine
längste Zeit im Regenwald das war ich
war für eine Philippinen gewesen und da
war Wochen lang da gewesen und ich auf
mindernow und den panai keine Angst
da nicht das Problem ist das größte
Problem ist die Luftfeuchtigkeit wenn du
98% Luftfeuchtigkeit hast schläfst du
nicht mehr dann wird dann schläft nicht
und dein Gehirn wird sowas wie so eine
wie so eine matschige Apfelsine
du wirst dumm du wirst immer dumpfer
wirklich physiologisch dann passiert was
das Gefühl du hast ja nur noch so ein
Schwamm ja du wirst so du merkst du das
merkt doch jeder schon wenn hier die
Luftfeuchtigkeit stark steigt und
kombiniert mit Hitze dass man so träge
ist und kein Gedanken mehr fassen kann
bei der Arbeit und das hat man ja hier
noch viel träger und das auch über einen
langen Zeitraum und dann passioniert
genug zur Seite die Humbold jedes
gelenkliche Phänomen das will ich ja das
ist spannend da muss ich hin den
schimmerato muss ich besteigen da muss
und so weiter die Energie Energie
[Musik]
ja unter solchen extrem
hardcorebedingungen war ja nicht nur im
Regenwald aber der ist auf dem Berg hoch
gestiegen wieder ohne Sauerstoff den
damaligen Ausrüstung die man hatte und
so also der hat sich ja ständig in
Gefahr gegeben und er wollte immer
weiter und er hat sein Wissensdurst
nie nachgelassen als können wir also
vorstellen da kommen auch Leute an die
finden das wahnsinnig spannend oh ich
bin in Südamerika und ich bin hier am
Regenwald und so weiter und die nach
einer Woche sagen ich will nach Hause
jetzt ist aber gut genau und das dann
über Jahre hinweg durchzuziehen und das
alles noch mit dem Reisen mit einer
Reise Medizin die nichts wert war also
wo man ja etwas hat man denn gemacht
wenn man wenn man Fieber kriegt besoffen
vielleicht oder dorthin getrunken
genauso wenn man verfügte ja nicht über
die modernen Mädels gab keine Malaria
Prophylaxe und nichts also das sind
irrsinniger Leistungen gewesen und wie
stark muss der innere Antrieb gewesen
sein also dieser dieser Junge aus Berlin
der sich in Büchern Büchern die Nase
platt gedrückt hat und gesagt hat ich
will das jetzt alles sehen und ich will
das entdecken und erforschen toll und
durchgezogen
ich hatte früher mal vorgehabt ein Buch
zu schreiben über Carl von Linné und
seine Schüler das passt auch gut zu kein
von Linné ist der Begründer der
wissenschaftlichen Nomenklatur das hier
Homo sapiens heißen verdanken wir Carl
von Linie also es gibt ein Familiennamen
und es gibt ein individuellen Namen also
homo ist der Mensch ja und sapiens ist
sozusagen der Abnahme und diese
lungenklatur hatte als erste aufgestellt
und er war damals der Mensch der von
Schweden aus von Uppsala aus die die die
wissenschaftliche Botanik erfunden hat
und auch die Grundlagen der
wissenschaftlichen Zoologie so und
dieser Mann zu dem reisten die Menschen
aus ganz Europa junge Studenten unter
anderem weil er viel erklärt über die
Befruchtung der Pflanzen und es war eine
der wenigen Möglichkeiten der damaligen
Gesellschaft vor allen Dingen so
protestantischen Ländern wie Schweden
über Sex reden zu können
ja es werden auch wahnsinnig gerne
Studentinnen und so weiter dahin
gekommen was aber in der damaligen Zeit
eben schwer Möglichkeiten man war völlig
faszinierend von dieser Welt Botanik war
ja in den adelsgesellschaften eine
riesen Hobby gewesen man gab mit seinen
Gärten an und was man damit machte und
staunen die man züchtete und Frauen die
man betörte durch Rosen die man anbaute
und so weiter und der war der Papst und
dann gegen diese Schüler alle dahin und
was macht Carl von nee er schickt sie in
die Welt weil er wollte ein
vollständiges natursystem entwerfen das
heißt aber müsste er alle Pflanzen und
Tiere kennen damit sein System aufgehen
klar jetzt schickt er diese 22
23-Jährigen Milchgesichter ja nach
Südamerika in den vorderen Orient nach
Afrika und so weiter und eigentlich
unerheblicher Teil ist da umgekommen
klar ja
also der gleichen Pflaster an seinen Weg
weil die sind natürlich da der hat ihn
ja keine Expedition sein könnte sondern
die sind auf Handelsschiffen angeheuert
ne und waren dann da irgendwo an Land
wahrscheinlich haben sich die anderen da
an Bord gemacht was macht der Spinner
hier
das einzige was man sinnvoll daran war
fand war immer der entdeckt jetzt
vielleicht noch irgendeine Pflanze sowie
die Kartoffel die wir bei uns anbauen
können und über gebrauchen können aber
für die anderen Sachen für die Nähe sich
interessiert der ging es nicht darum
immer die Pflanzen gebrauchen konnte ist
doch ein Lücken im System neue Gattungen
und so weiter und das ist das eine irre
Geschichte also verläuft wegen der
Südamerika stirbt und Hassel Quiz der im
vorderen Orient stirbt und so weiter der
ist eigentlich ein ungehobener Schatz
das ganze mal machen finde ich ja bei
dem was man im Leben sonst noch so alles
aber ein toller Stoff total und ich habe
mir immer überlegt wie der Schluss von
dem Buch sein muss
ja also er kriegt er noch mal irgendeine
Todesnachricht und dann geht er so das
hat er so Kreuze in seinem Garten in
uppsalat für seine Toten Schüler ja und
er geht sofort los an jeden vorbei und
denkt oh ich muss den Oleander reinholen
der Frost kommt
ja und der letzte Satz hätte geheißen
dass ihre Parabel Leben ist der
Überdruss
sehr schön schön du solltest das machen
Richard uppsala ist doch der war doch
hans Rosling hat doch auch da gelehrt ne
also warte ich weiß dass der berühmte
Statistiker ja kann ich gut sein kann
gut sein aber
eigentlich da durch die Nähe begründet
also in Schweden ist ja ja
Flughafen ankommst da sind ja die ganzen
berühmten Schweden findest du finde
ein anderes Thema aber ich habe noch mal
zum Schluss gefragt also weil du gerade
sagst Schiffe nee in Sachen Evolution
welche Rolle spielt die Tatsache dass
wir plötzlich sozusagen verbunden sind
mit der ganzen Welt also sag mal ganz
weit zurück einschleppen und ja genau
also wenn du sagst okay es gibt
Reptilien es gibt Krokodile in Afrika es
gibt sie aber auch irgendwie im fernen
Florida oder was auch immer so die alte
Pangea Idee ja irgendwann hing mal alles
zusammen ein großer Kontinent hat sich
dann auseinander entwickelt so
weil nur so kann es ja gewesen sein
irgendwie sicher dass das schwimmt ja
nicht einfach
Kontinentalverschiebung unserer heute
Handelsschiffe Beziehungen also ich
meine wenn so ein Handelsschiff hat
jetzt aus Versehen eine Art in
Australien mit dem mit dem Mehlsack
kommt jetzt noch irgendwie dein
tasmanischer
der schleicht sich da jetzt mit an Bord
versteckt sich hinter zwischen diesen
ganzen Müllsäcken ja und landet
plötzlich im Hamburger Hafen
was passiert dann also der die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sind hier von
der Größe das Wort für Wolf
aber natürlich schleppen wir im großen
Stil hier rein und was ich meine nicht
so der Gedanke also in welchem
atemberaubenden Tempo zerstören wieder
möglicherweise Arten die wir hier haben
also ja Millionen Evolution
weil einmal ein Schiff von Australien
nach Hamburg gefahren ist oder wenn
irgendwo mal ein alexandersittich einem
Züchter entkommen ist und im Rheinland
ist es schön im Sommer wenn die dicken
Schwärme von Papageien also ich wohne ja
da Pfeifen
da um die Häuser rum und so weiter ne
die kommen aus
Bergregionen in Indien da wird es
richtig kalt und deswegen überleben die
bei uns die Winter na und die brüten im
Baumhöhlen die nehmen dann den
schwächsten die Baumhöhlen weg und so
weiter die singt vor Singvogel Bestand
singt unter anderem wegen dieser
wunderschönen und das noch weniger
geworden
also als ich nach Köln kam waren die
schon da 87 aber noch nicht wollte aber
mittlerweile ist die ganze reinschiene
voll dann wirklich ja ist eine invasive
Art ja und jetzt sagt die Stadt ja was
sollen wir denn machen wir können sie
nicht hinstehen und mit Schrot die da
von den Bäumen schießen das ist da
gibt's keine gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz
für weil die auch hübsch sind weil die
auch hübsch sind und weil wenn da jemand
irgendwie im Park steht und Papageien
abschießt denken weil der hat sie nicht
mehr alle auf der Latte und wenn er noch
sagt die Stadt hat das angeordnet wird
keiner wieder gewählt also
keine ganz einfache Angelegenheit
biologisch evolutionärer Sicht ich will
jetzt hier keine komischen Vorschläge
machen aber ich sag mal ich stehe da so
in der Mitte ja es gibt natürlich auch
so ein
wenn man es brutal sagt artenfaschismus
der sagt ja wäre ich eigentlich nicht
hingehört der gehört hier nicht hin
andererseits muss man sagen Migration
unter Tieren er ist so alt wie das seit
des Tiere gibt also zumindest seit sie
die Möglichkeit hatten sich entsprechend
auszubreiten es hat immer schon
Tierarten gegeben auch Tierarten die wir
die Fasane die bei uns vorher laufen
Götter keiner hier hinten also ich meine
Idee wie heißt die auch noch
jagdversagen also das ist ja so eine
kunstmarke ist eigentlich der
chinesische ringfaserne kommt das China
zum Jagen ausgesetzt worden und ist
mittlerweile in Wildvogel der aber
eigentlich hier überhaupt nichts
verloren hat kommt ja auch keiner auf
die Idee und sagt wir müssen alle
fasaner abballern
rote schwarze Eichhörnchen ja die grauen
die grauen aus Nordamerika genau die
gehören die nicht hin also die roten
gehören hier hin aber die Frauen die
etwas größer sind ja ne und die haben
hier relativ wenig natürliche Feinde
vielleicht oder so aber sie setzen sich
gegenüber den den roten durch genau
übrigens wie mit den Amerikanern in
Berlin Mitte
ja ich bin ja viele in Berlin Mitte und
ich sehe es gibt sehr viel Amerikaner
und die Fallen auf weil sie sehr viel
lauter reden als deutsche auf der Straße
und vor allen Dingen in der Gastronomie
du sitzt da abends irgendwo und du
kannst dann eigenes Wort nicht verstehen
weil am Leben Tisch lachen und Grillen
die Amerikaner und ich denke auch meist
genau dasselbe die haben hier keine
natürlichen Feinde
[Musik]
aber du liebst Amerika Richard es ist
kein Satz gegen Amerika
die Lautstärke schon ein klein wenig
daran merkt man dass man alt wird Volker
sagen wenn du ein Palermo in der Kneipe
sitzt nicht anders in der italienische
so schön
das muss ich doch wirklich wieder sagen
also die sind so eine Sprache du hast
aber ja was ist tatsächlich so also bei
Spanisch und bei italienisch bin ich
wahnsinnig toll
amerikanische nervt mich ich sage das
ist wirklich das ist eine kommunistische
Erziehung die kommt ja immer wieder
durch der Klang der Sprache
wieder böse klassenfein ich hatte
herrlich das heißt Eichhörnchen von
Berlin ja ist der Laute Amerikaner junge
laute Amerikaner und ihr junge Leute
Amerikanerinnen
wunderbar mit der mit dem häufigsten
Satz oh mein Gott
sage ich doch kommen so alte alte
resondere darf ich Mamma Mia oder was
was ich Wasser ja es war ja die junge
Leute Italienerin gibt es ja auch kaum
noch im Italiener King ja kaum noch
Kinder das Problem riesiges Drama ja
wenn du in Rom im Restaurant sitzt dann
siehst Du wirklich wie sich ganz wie
groß Familien Scharen um ein einziges
Kind ja wirklich aber weißt du was zum
biologischen Thema
in Spanien und in Spanien sitzen die
Kinder bis Mitternacht auch die kleinen
Kinder da noch beim Essen und so weiter
die Essen alles und pennen dann weg und
pennen dann weg und keiner schreit und
keiner nervt und keiner will eine
Extrawurst und so weiter also ich denke
wir können von den Südländern so viele
über Kindererziehung gegangen diese
beiläufigen mitlaufen selbst wenn sieben
oder acht Leute ein Kind umsorgen sie
stellen ihn nie die Frage was es will
und das ist sehr gut so je weniger man
Kindern die Frage stellt was Sie wollen
umso unzähliger werden sich ja für mich
ein völlig neues Konzept ja ich fragen
einfach machen und vorsetzen mitlaufen
lassen respektieren ja ich sage immer
Kinder können nicht genug Liebe kriegen
aber leicht zu viel Aufmerksamkeit und
ich finde das kann man an den Südländern
so wunderbar lernen wie man Liebe gibt
ohne Aufmerksamkeit zu überzeichnen um
um um das jetzt noch mal sozusagen ganz
kurz zum Schluss wieder zu unserem Thema
zurückzuführen machen privaten auch so
Frage ja das beiläufige mitnehmen ja das
ist natürlich klar die Kinder klammern
sich fest und sind immer wie die
spanischen Kindern dann wird der
Gastronomie immer mit dabei ja ohne dass
sie deswegen im Mittelpunkt stehen kann
man sagen ist gutes privaten Verhalten
aus guten Gründen Millionen Jahre lang
unverändert wir fangen gerade an das zu
verändern
jetzt zum Schluss noch schnell eine
Szene in Ghana ein ich war mal mit eine
Frau auf ihrem erdnussfeld in Ghana ich
habe mal mein Leben für eine Reportage
mit dem Leben einer gambianischen
Hausfrau getauscht wie 24 Stunden weil
die härteste Erfahrung meines Lebens
unfassbar für so eine Fernsehserie für
eine Reportage ich wollte ich wollte mal
zeigen was das wirklich bedeutet bei 40
42 45 Grad zu Hause den Haushalt zu
schmeißen schmeißen das Wasser Kilometer
weit auf dem Kopf erstmal durch die
Gegend zu tragen nebenbei noch die
Kinder zu versorgen und Ganzen nebenbei
auf dem erdnussfeld unfassbar harte
Arbeit zu machen in dieser glühenden
Sonne und da habe ich das damals auch so
mitgekriegt dann hat sie mir erzählt ich
habe dann die Kinder dahin geschleppt
und dann sagte sie mir so und die setzt
du jetzt einfach da ab und die sagte nee
geht doch nicht aber die Kinder Herbst
Kinder sagt doch doch einfach ab und
dann gehen wir auf dieses Feld und haben
dann dort in Senken der Sonne in dieser
Gluten irgendwie Erdnüsse daraus geholt
und dann gucke ich immer so wo die
Kinder sind und es war total schön
keiner hat Theater gemacht keiner hat
Rambazamba gemacht die größeren auf die
kleineren aufgepasst im Schatten eines
großen Baumes und das lief wunderbar mit
der größten Selbstverständlichkeit auf
Erden und dann ging sie wieder zurück
und natürlich ich habe den dann auch
gehen sollen auf dem Rücken drauf oder
vorne oder auch immer kannst du die
aussuchen und dann sehen wir dann nach
Hause und das hat mir damals gut
gefallen das habe ich in der Mongolei
auch so ähnlich gesehen in der Mongolei
laufen die Kinder auch so nebenbei mit
der guckst du guckst aus dem aus der
Jurte raus und dann reite der kleine
irgendwie auf seinem Steppen fährt
einfach mit fünf sechs Jahren hält sich
einfach nur sondern mir eine fest kein
Sattel kann nichts und reitet einfach
los und kommt zurück mit komplett
offenen Beinen offenen Oberschenkel und
vorstellbar
ein Vertrauen Grenze los und dann nicht
meine These sagen dass wir uns im
Hinblick auf die Kindererziehung einfach
ein ganzes Stück weit zu sehr
entbiologie
natürlichen Instinkte im Umgang mit
Kindern mehr und mehr verlieren
ja und dass das diesen Kindern auch am
Ende nicht gut tut die gebe ich dir
Recht ich glaube dass wir diese Instinkt
interessanterweise bisschen die heutige
Zeit auch alle haben ja also total
interessant genau und und deswegen habe
ich mich immer gewehrt auch gegen so
komische Bücher wie jedes Kind kann
schlafen lernen immer gedacht nee warte
mal es hat doch einen Sinn biologisch
dass ich jetzt leichter Schlaf wenn
nachts der Kleine schreit und ich diese
Frequenz für mein Ohr als besonders
penetrant wahrnehmen Alter dann stehe
jetzt auf dann soll das sein und dann
steht doch auch auf wie bringst du denn
dann fertig den dann fünf Minuten
einfach hinter verschlossener Tür in der
Dunkelheit Weinen zu lassen furchtbar
die Prophezeiungen und das zeigt dir wie
weit wir weg sind waren immer furchtbar
die Prophezeiungen waren das wird er nie
lernen nie alleine einschlafen und du
wirst bis der 10 ist wird der ständig
dich nach Heim suchen nichts dergleichen
das Gegenteil war der Fall weil die
Kinder irgendwann dieses Urvertrauen
klar haben und wissen okay wenn die
Hütte richtig brennt
kommt jemand und ansonsten ist alles gut
und dann ergibt sich das ganz von selbst
deswegen
wirklich immer mein petitum höher auf
die Instinkte was was Kinder als jung
angeht man kriegt dann schon Gefühl
dafür wann sie mit die den Molly machen
aber wenn du dann wenn du dieses Gefühl
noch hast ich habe das jedenfalls das
Gefühl verliert ja was ist wirklich in
Not ja was ist nur ein bisschen
Aufmerksamkeit was ist Übermüdung was
ist ein Problem
muss auch mal ein bisschen schreien
aushalten können aber jetzt sind wir ja
am Ende eines Gesprächs über Biologie
und Artenvielfalt für Kindererziehung
gekommen ich werde eigentlich gern von
Dir wissen Markus noch am Ende dieses
Jahr ist der Einsamkeit und dieses
Sterben der Arten wenn du wenn du dir
das jetzt so vergegenwärtigst
was löst das in dir für Gefühle aus
also soll ich dir sagen wo es für mich
am plastischsten wurde Vögel und
Fledermäuse
fledermäuse sind ja nicht die Tiere
Stichwort Corona die wir besonders
lieben ja Coronaviren und so weiter
aber wenn wir die verlieren wenn wir
bestimmte Vogelarten verlieren die
Früchte essen dann Kerne irgendwann
irgendwo fallen lassen wenn du dann noch
weißt du weißt das ganz genau ein ganz
bestimmter Vogel ist evolutionär so
gestaltet dass nur er in der Lage ist
ganz besonders große Kerne fallen zu
lassen nur der kann das welcher ist das
ja also für riesigen Schnabel
und dann wachsen bestimmte Bäume nicht
mehr mit wickeltation plötzlich wenn du
nachweisen kannst das mit abnehmender
vogelzahl auch Vegetation sich verändert
kein gutes Gefühl kein gutes Gefühl für
die Zukunft der Menschheit und wenn man
deine Kinder längst oder auch bei mir
ich denke gar nicht so viel jetzt an
meinen Sohn da denke ich auch dran aber
ich denke da paralleligiös ja ich denke
wie viel Millionen Jahre hat das alles
gebraucht und und dieser Zauber zu
werden ist auch manchmal brutal ja und
kann auch grausam sein und so weiter
aber ist auch aus meiner Perspektive
unendlich schön ja ich bin ich nehme das
als Mensch soweit die Tiere im Wald
vielleicht nicht aber ich nehme das so
war und diese Vorstellung dass das alles
verschwindet und genichtet wird und wenn
das alles mal weg ist dann ist ja nichts
in der Welt besser geworden sondern das
ist viel viel schlimmer geworden und
trotzdem haben wir dieses Thema im
Gegensatz zum Klimawandel unter
vermischt ist auf der Tagungsort
Tagesordnung
ich bin vor wenigen Tagen am
Wirtschaftsministerium vorbeigekommen
das große Schild Ministerium für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und ich denke
ja für Klimaschutz ein Aspekt der großen
umweltverschwörung und das an die
anderen Aspekte die sind alle irgendwie
angegliedert beim Umweltministerium das
ein ganzes Stück entfernt ist also
vermischt ist ja Gerhard Schröder hätte
fast noch wahrscheinlich Gedöns dazu
gesagt genau weil nur das Klima so raus
geschält ist jetzt das große Thema
Zerstörung der Artenvielfalt der enorme
Ressourcenverbrauch beides geht eng
miteinander zusammen richtig ja wenn wir
kommen
Kobalt aus Afrika kriegen dann geht das
einher mit regenwaldrodung ja je mehr
Autos bei uns waren auch Elektroautos
die zum ersten Smartphones wir haben
umso mehr Kontakt brauchen wir umso mehr
wird die Umwelt und die Natur das geht
alles weiter weiter und weiter
da habe ich manchmal das Gefühl ich bin
irgendwie froh dass ich noch so viel
Schönes von der Natur erlebt habe aber
es beruhigt mich nicht ich finde es
unendlich schade ja das künftige
Generationen das nicht mehr erleben
werden und das fasst mich regelrecht mit
der physisch an und nicht unter der
nutzensfrage kann die Mensch leben oder
sowas ja sondern wir machen die Welt in
einem irrsinnigen Ausmaß um ihre
Schönheit ärmer in diesem Sinne Richard
das war ein sehr interessanter Austausch
viel gelernt ich auch
einen schönen verregneten Sommer
weiterhin auch
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]